ich würde sogar noch einen Schritt
weiter gehen die Ampel ist dabei
Deutschland vor die Wand zu fahren ich
bringe ihn einfach mal ein Beispiel mit
wie weit es mittlerweile gekommen ist
aus Westfalen gestern in der Zeitung
eine Fleischerei ich darf den Namen auch
einen Goldbecker weil es ja öffentlich
war diese Fleischerei hat 25 Angestellte
die sind jetzt alle arbeitslos der
Besitzer Herr Goldbecker argumentiert
und sagt ich kann die Stromkosten die
Arbeitskosten und das alles nicht mehr
bezahlen aber ein großer Tropfen war das
schöne Beispiel mit dem was was ist zum
Überlaufen bringt war der Punkt
Bürokratie ich zitiere ihn er sagt ist
der Putzplan geschrieben darauf muss ich
aufpassen haben die Mitarbeiter im Laden
einen Erste Hilfe Kurs eine
truppführerausbildung eine Schulung in
Sachen Brandschutz gemacht sind die
Temperaturen in der Kühlung fortlaufend
dokumentiert ist die Zutatenliste
detailliert genug darf man das
Zigeunerschnitzel noch Zigeunerschnitzel
nennen und jetzt kommt Hammer wenn das
Schule macht dann war es das er sagt als
Fazit Zitat ich kann jedem nur raten
sich nicht selbstständig zu machen schon
gar nicht Leute einzustellen in der
Schule macht geht Deutschland vor die
Hunde deshalb brauchen wir einen Plan
wie wir da wieder rauskommen ich würde
ihnen holzschnittsartig nennen erstens
sofort ein Bürokratie und
belastungsstoff für Bürger und Betriebe
zweitens sofort eine Steuerreform die
sich wirklich nur auf die Mitte auf die
arbeitende Bevölkerung konzentriert wir
haben alle Gruppen in den letzten Jahren
und Jahrzehnten gedacht nur diese Gruppe
ist zu wenig bedacht worden drittens wir
brauchen fordern und fördern aber das
fordern muss wieder gestärkt werden
derjenige der arbeiten kann muss eine
Arbeit annehmen und diejenigen die nicht
arbeiten können müssen stärker
unterstützt werden viertens wir müssen
Bildung zu einer nationalen Aufgabe
machen das heißt junge Leute Kinder die
eingeschult werden müssen der Sprache
der deutschen Sprache mächtig sein und
wer das nicht ist muss verpflichtend in
die Vorschule um diese Kinder
drangsalieren wie einige sagen sondern
um sie zu fördern und fünftens und
letztens der Staat muss die Freiheit des
Einzelnen Stärken er darf nicht gängeln
und bevormunden er darf den Menschen
nicht vorschreiben was sie anzuziehen
haben wie sie zu sprechen haben oder wie
sie zu heizen haben und um das
umzusetzen braucht es Voraussetzung ich
finde eine Voraussetzung in Zukunft
sollte sein dass wenn jemand ein
politisches Mandat annimmt zumindest mal
eine Berufsausbildung wenn nicht etwas
gearbeitet zu haben damit das
Verständnis auch da ist um Politik
wirklich für die Menschen zu machen
[Gelächter]
wie vielen Punkten würden Sie zustimmen
da waren fünf Punkte dabei ich kann mir
vorstellen da finden selbst jetzt Linke
und CDU auch Überschneidungen oder ja
ich finde natürlich auch dass man kleine
und mittelständische Unternehmen
entlasten sollte aber um die
Bildungsmisere mal anzusprechen ich
meine aus den Schulen da tropft
irgendwie der Asbest von der Decke wir
haben viel zu wenig Lehrkräfte und 16
Jahre hatten wir eine CDU geführte
Bundesregierung da haben sie ja nicht so
viel dafür getan eine Bundespolitik mit
Bildungspolitik zu tun ist ja ganz neu
unglaublich sind ja auch ein
Landesregierung beteiligt und ähm
irgendwie in unsere Zukunft zu
investieren und wenn sie sagen man darf
irgendwie hier kein heizdiktat oder
sowas machen die Transformation kommt so
oder so es wäre viel dümmer nicht in die
Transformation zu investieren wir müssen
ja sozusagen die ökologische Wände
schaffen
weil der hat jetzt nämlich 80.000 €
Stromkosten mehr wenn man dem einfach
nur sagt die Transformation die wird
sowieso kommen dann müssen wir mit
Kindern ist diesem Mann der sein Leben
lang gearbeitet hat und jetzt alle
rauswerfen muss nicht geholfen also
meine Frage wird an diese Menschen an
diesen Fall den ein Lindemann hier
mitgebracht hat wirklich gedacht nein
ich rede jetzt von großen Konzernen vor
allem auch in der stadtindustrie wo wir
umrüsten müssen als wären sie tun man
könnte zum Beispiel über einen
Strompreis für die Industrie diskutieren
also dass die nicht so explodieren die
Preise wie wir das jetzt in den letzten
Monaten und Jahren irgendwie hatten
wobei die ja auch mittlerweile wieder
sinken und da muss man da darüber reden
dass eben nicht damit horrende Gewinne
gemacht werden sondern dass wir dort
eben vernünftige Regelungen haben dass
wir preisdeckel haben damit sich
sozusagen ja der Bäcker wurde vorhin
angesprochen die nicht irgendwie an
ihren Stromkosten ersticken die Sie
bezahlen müssen das ist ein typisches
Verhaltensmuster der Politik erst denkt
man das Angebot an Energie ein geht aus
Kernkraft raus dann ist der Staat der
größte Preistreiber beim Strompreis mehr
als 50% letztendlich abgabensteuer
nimmt den Leuten das Weg den Betrieben
und dann kommt er ganz stolz mit breiter
Brust und sagt jetzt subventioniere ich
euch übrigens wie bei den Familien die
Familien in Deutsch it die wichtigste
und kleinste Keimzelle die nämlich
erstmal das Geld weg die haben am mit am
wenigsten netto um danach mit 147
Familienprogramm zu sagen jetzt komme
ich statt und unterstütze euch was ist
das für ein Menschenbild von
Gesellschaft mit trauen sie den Menschen
das selbst nicht so ich traue den
Menschen ziemlich viel zu und vor allem
auch die Politik der letzten Jahre zu
bewerten und es war ja so dass wir als
Deutschland auch mal Vorreiter bei
Solarenergie beispielsweise waren das
wurde alles zerstört oder alles kaputt
gemacht und jetzt guckt man sich
irgendwie um oder die nordischen Länder
die haben das mit der Wärmepumpe schon
längst gelöst die heizen damit und das
funktioniert gut und das ist ja sogar
kälter hier wurde einfach der
Politikwechsel verschlafen hier wurde es
verschlafen auf die drängenden Probleme
auch tragfeste Antworten zu entwickeln
und da ist natürlich auch
denken
die Bildungspolitik ist originell in der
Sache da sollte man mal darüber
diskutieren ob das wirklich richtig ist
Österreich gehen in die Schweiz nein man
braucht natürlich Konzepte die kleine
und mittelständische Betriebe entlasten
und ich meine in Deutschland werden ja
kleine und mittlere Vermögen auch ja
stärker belastet als sehr sehr hohe
Vermögen und da muss man Ausgleich haben
also muss die niedrigen entlassen und
man muss die großen höher besteuern aber
stellte sie als biologisch auch einmal
reinholen da halten sie das Tempo beim
Klimaschutz derzeit für angemessen also
ich sehe die die ganze Klimapolitik der
aktuellen Ampelkoalition als sehr sehr
kritisch also ich glaube da wird will
man jetzt sozusagen mit massiven Druck
ähm Änderungen herbeiführen von denen
ausgesprochen fraglich ist ob sie
überhaupt sinnvoll sind und man wird
massiv auch ganz viele Menschen belasten
mit hohen Kosten die vielleicht dazu
sogar führen dass sie ihr hart
erarbeitetes Häuschen verlieren und für
den für das Klima ist es doch ganz ganz
fraglich ob das Ganze überhaupt was
nützt ob
positioniert und ob es was nützt ich
glaube da da ist eine massive
Fehlsteuerung die jetzt stattfinden soll
und vielleicht der Bogen zu dem was wir
vorhin gerade hatten ich habe den
Bereich dass er den den Eindruck das in
vielen Bereichen Fehlsteuerung
stattgefunden hat zum Beispiel im
Gesundheitsbereich aber auch in anderen
also im Finanzbereich und der
Hintergrund dieser Fehlsteuerung ist
glaube ich dass die dass viele Politiker
nicht mehr Politik für die Menschen
machen sondern für bestimmte
Interessengruppen die sehr finanzkräftig
sind die sehr viel Einfluss Einfluss
haben als Lobby-Organisation und dass
das dazu geführt hat dass es eine
massive Schere gibt zwischen denen die
wenig haben die teilweise auch durch
hohe Steuern belastet sind und
denjenigen die viel haben und immer mehr
anhäufen also die Zahlen belegen das ja
dass das auseinander geht und die zum
Teil so viel verdienen und dann wieder
Möglichkeiten haben
Fett keine Steuern zu zahlen was
haarsträubend ist und das sind
Fehlsteuerungen wo man mal gucken muss
und da kommt vielleicht die
Naturwissenschaftlerin ins Spiel die ich
bin man muss doch mal gucken was sind
die Ursachen warum warum ist es dazu
gekommen und dann muss man an diese
Ursachen gehen und ich für meinen
Gefühlen ist Lobbyismus und der
zunehmende Einfluss auch von großen
Finanzinvestoren ein Kernproblem und das
muss behoben werden und das muss
aufgedeckt werden und da haben
Journalisten eine große Aufgabe die sie
leider teilweise nicht so gut erfüllen
darüber sprechen wir auch noch gleich
mit Ihnen Frau Weber auch die Linke
strauchfrage werden sie das Gefühl dass
man ja Kontaktes Gefühl wirklich das
Verständnis für viele Wählerinnen und
Wähler verloren hat den Friseur
Supermarkt Mitarbeiter dass man da an
diesen ganz ja ganz realen Problem
überhaupt nicht mehr dran ist also wir
befassen uns ja eigentlich 24/7 mit
diesen Problemen und sind natürlich auch
sozusagen versuchen da Lösungen
anzubieten aber woran wir arbeiten
müssen ist natürlich wieder unsere
gesellschaftliche Verankerung und dann
auch wieder Wahlen zu gewinnen aber wir
hatten erst jetzt bei Bremen wo wir
unser Ergebnis gehalten haben wo wir
jetzt auch wieder eine rot-grün-rote
Regierung bilden werden unsere
Wirtschaftssenatorin dort und unsere
Gesundheitssenatorin wurden an den
Wahlkampfständen sehr sehr gelobt weil
sie eine pragmatische Politik gemacht
haben weil sie sozusagen eine Politik
orientiert am Wähler auch gemacht
also klar gibt's immer wieder wir müssen
jetzt natürlich auch Erfolge vorweisen
aber ich frage mich grundsätzlich ist
ähm das habe ich gerade überhaupt nicht
Fragen gestellt ob es ein grundsätzlich
ist auch wenn ihre Umfrage nach unten
gehen ein grundsätzliches Vertrauens
Problem gibt und auch ihre Parteien
damit zu kämpfen hat ja also ich denke
dass wir grundsätzlichen Problem des
Vertrauensverlustes in die Politik haben
also wenn wir uns anschauen die nicht
wählerquote also wie viele Menschen
gehen überhaupt nicht mehr zur Wahl dann
geht am Ende nur noch irgendwie 50% der
Bevölkerung zur Wahl weil es sozusagen
das Gefühl gibt bei den Menschen ja egal
was ich wähle irgendwie bringt es mir
nichts und ich finde da sind wir auch
als Demokratie gefordert dem
entgegenzuwirken und auch als Linke
natürlich